Erte you're at you're on to the on to
the Andy BAM ones coming in because
we're about to talk about
XCOM to myself and Mike got to play the
I guess it's just a preview build yeah
over the holidays pretty sizable part of
the game yeah pretty long I haven't gone
anywhere near the ending of it Andy you
play this just before the holiday break
I did and you put up a video for a
holiday break about it it's like you
were for it go watch that go yeah but
don't right now
cuz we're doing this one but wait but
wait there's more so later what exactly
did you get a play if you you got to
start from scratch right they sort of
popped us in right let's play tutorial
then they're like all right here we're
gonna bunt bump you up and you already
have a squad you know do this and I was
like I was lost because there's so much
going on yeah and I think that's one of
the main takeaways of XCOM compared to X
come to is the X come to is just like
holy [ __ ] a lot of story so much stuff
which is almost all embargoed so we are
talking which is for the best because
that's pretty good yeah we we could say
there's very much an overarching story
that yes it's coming into it but I think
it's the extent of what we can talk okay
all right so well but the the preview
build we saw was essentially this the
game it just I guess it stops closer to
the end it doesn't show you all of it
but we did all the early like tutorial
stuff all the early stuff again like I
had talked a lot of bad oh god a lot
I died in the tutorial oh well I think
you have yeah I think you have to wait
did you get wiped in this tutorial I got
white dude I just read the tutorial
Mohamed you also see you've wiped a
couple of times you're playing a tire
iron man at the moment I have to so the
first question was a lot of people
worried about this because it's like
sequel to or some people weren't worried
because the changing up a lot of the
enemies and your kind of your role as
your good this gorilla sort of aspect
instead of being on the front lines is
it has it been nerfed has the difficulty
been nerfed or does it feel as difficult
I was like a good XCOM pain XCOM to
feels substantially harder than playing
on normal they call normal veteran
like they sit okay if you're not playing
an easy you know there's those prompts
next to it yes No
says play if you are a seasoned XCOM
player okay and then there's two more
difficulties after that I've been
planning on normal with Ironman just
because you know I really like the
permadeath again not being able to
reload saves and I've there's been four
separate campaigns I've started that I
had to just start over I was screwed Wow
is it was it fun oh yeah yeah yeah and
like Andy said there's so much to keep
track of that's why I'm really glad that
they didn't pop me into something let me
start from scratch because you know
you're learning with each of these new
abilities when you like go up to
corporal or sergeant needs your person
you know you could attach these
characters and you're like oh tanya has
long shot so like you know long sight so
I know that she can protect everybody
from her sniper perch and then you know
this character has this machine-gun
ability to suppress them you really get
to know the characters and then the
campaign I'm in right now I've only lost
two people about four hours and so you
know if you play Dex calm you kind of
get yeah it's tense really when and my
ones the ham you're gonna get too
confident it's all gonna go to [ __ ] and
one episode ins we for them dead in a
mission oh yeah I'll start dashing more
and then not having overwatch in the new
they'll get way down and actually that's
an interesting point because you're
saying in your video Andy the sort of
the roles have been overwatch is like
this whole out of the ball game that
because the roles have been reversed
instead of you kind of jumping into what
is essentially a bunch of aliens waiting
for you to come you are now the I guess
the guerrilla warfare going in and sort
of striking him so they don't know
you're there so right from the off
you're kind of already in stealth mode
like waiting to like do your initial
attack yeah and it's way better because
first of all in in the original game
you're like by the time you've played
that game a lot in your like getting
good at it you know you have to like
move in little little spurts
leapfrogging and it's it's all kind of I
don't know or like every the first five
minutes of every mission every session
is the same and tell you like launch
into the thing and the alien sees you
and then everything is good but in this
one it's like oh you can actually think
tactically set up an ambush go around or
even like try and complete the mission
without ever being seen oh wow
at all a lot of the missions do have a
trigger point though so it's like you
gotta steal this thing off the train and
then everybody gets alerted even if
you've stayed out of sight and you could
you like potentially run after that and
just try to get the hell out of there
because these these missions and Escom
to have
extractions mechanic where you like get
to a thing you throw down like a flare
whatever and the it comes and you just
get everybody there it's weird like
they've added a bunch of like the
mission types are a lot more varied as
well it's not just the kill everyone
scenario which those would have been
because you were basically going to
crash UFO sites and clearing them but
like now it's like a lot more extraction
stuff a lot more you're like timers we
have to get to bombs and stuff
and what I like about that sort of intro
part mike is the whole the line of sight
of the of the enemies like sometimes
they're on patrols so sometimes your
line of sight is moving between yeah
turns crazy yeah and there's these red
tiles that shows like an eye on it you
know if you step on that they're gonna
alert you unless you get this ability
later on with the Rangers when I walk
right through those really awesome
yeah because and then my the Ranger
there who has that also has one where if
the rest of the team so they see one of
your team members the entire team's
revealed oh but I haven't won this one
Ranger her name's Kelly she's she's
Irish I love how you know their names as
well that's yeah that's why I love this
game and you know she's she's got this
ability where the rest of team gets
revealed but she stays concealed so you
can flank with her perfect so you'd be
like a 95% chance to hit and it's
critical she's got this like laser
shotgun oh it's awesome and yeah the
mission objectives just changed so much
there's you know like extract like Andy
said sometimes you can just sneak up you
have this thing you have to extract and
then you can just get right up to that
without alerting the enemy if you're
good enough or patient enough I guess
unless there's a timer which those ones
like I'm such a I'm a really
conservative player like I I almost have
if I have like a five person squad I'll
have four on overwatch and have one move
up and yeah but this forces you to
really go outside your comfort zone even
more so than the one which is so good
about it
XCOM it's like cuz all the wheels are
turning in your head and then something
goes wrong and forces you to adapt and
that timer is just another wheel so it
feels like a lot more I don't know that
it's like that thing we talked to Jake
about complexity makes it look feel more
real because there's more things moving
so it feels less like a system and more
like a okay I need to like figure this
out like a sort of a real-world dynamic
sort of thing and one thing one thing I
I certainly haven't talked about in
stuff we've covered and and I think gets
left out a lot because it's sort of like
just a it's just another x-com you know
mechanic is you get this like drone
thing with one of your characters it
flies around okay they can like
pack [ __ ] and one of the coolest things
they've done it's this is really hard to
explain without like being able to see
it in person right
but basically you you have like three
options of hacking like a easy version
that just like gets it done a harder
version that like has a percent chance
of like giving you some sort of bonus or
like a super hard version that has like
a really small chance of giving you like
a really good bonus but also [ __ ] you
if you don't think that's off an alarm
resilient and like just like poison gas
just comes over the whole team you die
or something like that I don't know if
it's that traumatically I'm sure like
there is one that is that bad
so that and and that thing can just like
go so far so a lot of the missions you
can like you know stay stealthy and then
use that thing to go in and like do the
hacking turn like a turret against oh
wow so there's just like all these other
options that it gives you because a lot
of the bad guys in this are they have
guns they're not the sectoid as you know
the first tier enemy a first game
they're like dudes with guns is
basically like and they also have like
cars that they pull up in and handles
and you saw this in the original trailer
that they release where you like hacking
it and turns it against it but those are
like all over the place because and but
here's the question - I just thought of
the things are procedural so potentially
you guys are playing raw beginning but
having completely different Maps oh yeah
oh and like where are those points are
that you can hack us up or probably be
different I'm like if there's a gun here
and my game in mind up either in your
game or whatever so you like that's
something we need to experiment with
when we get the game for sure
yeah and this is why it's so exciting
because XCOM was kind of like based on
UFO defense or enemy Unknown if you're
living in Europe and which we're kind of
games that we knew a bad like they took
that they described as some of the more
superfluous like base building stuff
specifically and they kind of made this
super tight game but it was kind of we
knew what it was like if you played
Analects con game you knew an expo so
the sort of the the thing the one
criticism you could say of XCOM was it
wasn't very playable because it was kind
of the same thing over and over again
and also was kind of like we knew what
it was
whereas what we're talking about here
we're mentioning like the hacking the
drones the fact that you're on like the
other side of the the
the combat scenario the fact that
there's all these different types of
bodies like this game is just so varied
and that's why it's like so exciting not
for like one reason but for like all of
the reasons combined it just feels like
good what doesn't feel like a simple
sequel at all oh no and the strategy
layer like I haven't I don't even know
how it builds up mm-hmm
but like the part that dropped us in it
was like already like all these missions
to choose from you want to go get
technology here you better do that but
you're wasting time because the enemy is
building a thing and if you don't like
stop them and like the game is just done
and your base flies yes yeah those dark
events are the ones up until then that
you're still you're spending a fair
amount of time in the strategy layer
with your ship and like clearing out
because you're really you're rebuilding
you're clearing out alien debris from
like the lower levels okay that gives
you supplies and you allocate engineers
to do that but you're also moving around
like the map and then you're
establishing connection with the
resistance cell here so you can go to
like the Arctic from the western United
States but good arcs to Kristen suck but
then there's later like about three
hours anymore blankets like that it's
like the troops in Russia World War two
it's uh it's there's that like auntie
said there are these dark events that
the enemy you pretty much it shows you
their overall war strategy oh wow a
mission will pop up every once in a
while and if you hover over it'll say
this will counter that dark event oh
cool so one dark event it'll say like
it'll take two week longer to build
anything that's a long time especially
when you're not doing well and then it
says but you know if you succeed this
mission that'll negate that and you'll
also get the bonus from something else
and so you more so than the first game
you're you feel like you're just you
know you're on borrowed time the entire
time and it's it very much at this it's
a sequel in the best way possible it's
from what we've played I can't you know
speak to the whole game but so far it
feels like if you're an ex-con player
you're gonna like it you know what
you're getting into but as soon as you
figure out you're like okay this is
similar to the first game then they
throw like a lot of things at you not
you're not you're overwhelmed but in a
good way you're figuring things out and
you know by the time I was in my fifth
campaign I'm like all right so the
specialist limited drones you can either
make them a medic because you can do a
remote yelling right which I which I
real
love having like I try to bring like to
medkits with me so but you can also like
Annie said make them a hacker you find
these towers and you know be like you
know you get a 50% chance if you succeed
your you'll have a 75% more critical hit
chance Oh what if you fail every time
you get hit it's gonna do three extra
damage or know which one your soldiers
have five health the beginning I don't
know what I want to do that I'm they
shoot hard the enemies in this game take
off a shedload of health and we haven't
even mentioned the customization oh yeah
and like more fun because you put like
decals on your guns name your guns
there's like way more intricate stuff
you can make like a little mods
basically there's like a pool of dudes
and dudettes you can make which
basically go pull every game like so you
can just make your mom once yeah and
she'll be in like Shamu or she might
show up she might show up as part of the
resistance I think as well what the min
is like all the practice to its yeah
they show up in like the Skype cams when
they're asking for help and I I made I
made Mike McCarty you right off the bat
just because oh yeah yeah and I gave him
like this red bandana on his gun is red
and black and it looks like the gears
were Saul rifle first mission gets to
knife in the face might open your game
now and then as soon as that game comes
out there's mod support so there's even
better guns decals and stuff like the
macho man mod is gonna be there I think
I think the three of us are probably
like folks who would be very skeptical
of a bad ex-con game I feel like we'd be
very sensitive to a bad ex-con game but
it sounds like we're all on the same
page just games pretty [ __ ] fun and
we're really excited about it yeah
February 5th
yeah you don't know you're the [ __ ]
yeah yeah I can fight with my Hardy I
can't wait to get the full game every
fifth yeah there you go
let us know if you're excited about XCOM
dos dos x : give it to everyone in the
comments below thanks very much
you